[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette à proximité de Tokyo au Japon que
ce sont déroulés les championnats du
monde de patinage de vitesse
[Musique]
le sprinter soviétique grishing que l'on
voit ici en pleine action a remporté le
500 mètres mais la grande vedette de ces
championnats c'est le Suédois Johnny
Nilsson qui s'est permis le luxe de
battre trois records du monde au cours
de ces championnats
d'ailleurs d'une façon générale les
Nordiques ont repris leur suprématie sur
les Soviétiques actuellement en déclin
si la glace rend les bateaux
inutilisables elle a du moins l'avantage
de rendre les canaux carrossables ainsi
ont résonné les automobilistes
hollandais qui ont trouvé de la sorte
une compensation aux rayures
exceptionnelles de l'hiver
jalonné par des stations services
mobiles une nouvelle route s'est ouverte
à travers le zuderzé et personne n'a
regretté le ferry boat
[Musique]
il est bon de temps en temps de
retrouver un terrain solide sous ses pas
quand on est condamné à vivre sur l'eau
c'est ce que deux mois de gel ont offert
au
les footballeurs français ont attendu
presque un an et demi pour renouer avec
la victoire voici le début signé
vizneywski du festival offensive de
l'équipe de France face à l'Angleterre
au Parc des Princes à Paris
et de deux douilles en effet ajoute un
second but à l'actif de l'attaque
française il est vrai que les défenseurs
britanniques lancent et maladroits
pratiquent le football de grand papa le
coup de grâce avant la mi-temps un
troisième but que marque cossu les
Anglais cependant un peu mortifiés ont
essayé de forcer le destin dès le début
de la seconde mi-temps ils sont parvenus
à remonter deux buts au moment où ils
ont l'espoir d'égaliser business qui
leur
donne le coup et puis pour faire bonne
mesure et pour prouver que l'équipe de
France est sur la bonne voie Koso ajoute
un cinquième but ce sera le dernier 5 à
[Musique]
le Salon des Arts Ménagers 80.000 m²
1800 exposants faites cette année son
40e anniversaire 40 ans d'armes ménagers
c'est assez pour remplir une
encyclopédie et même plusieurs devant
pareil Yama de savoir et de savoir-faire
codifier Montaigne serait aujourd'hui
comblée lui qui disait la plus utile et
honorable science et occupations pour
une femme c'est la science du ménage il
avait évidemment oublié le célibataire
visiteurs consciencieux c'est à lui sans
nul doute que le Salon des Arts Ménagers
offre le plus d'occasion de rêver son
cœur et David de confort sa soif de
découvrir est inépuisable et que ne
réserve pas un miroir
Saint-Gobain offre un aperçu des
multiples rôles que le verre peut jouer
dans un foyer
[Musique]
le vert est glace mais il est aussi
isolant si les greniers ne sont guère
habités de nos jours par les fantômes
ils le sont encore par les courants
d'air un simple revêtement de laine de
verre permet d'ishaler les toits et de
gagner ainsi une pièce d'habitation dans
la maison autant ou la crise du logement
ne semble pas encore résolue voici donc
une solution astucieuse et amusante à la
portée du bricolage
et le vert c'est encore des verres à
boire bien sûr mais aussi des plats des
assiettes aux formes nouvelles qui
peuvent être mises entre toutes les
mains même les plus maladroites les
armes ménagées le voilà bien le paradis
du célibataire
[Musique]
on va construire une cité à Hérouville
c'est-à-dire plusieurs quartiers autour
d'un centre avec son commerce et son
administration pour la circulation plus
de Carrefour des branches en y
les voitures ne rentrent pas dans les
quartiers réservés aux piétons mais il
faut tout voir pour comprendre
l'urbanisme alors reprenons au début et
suivant l'opération qui se prépare près
de Caen pour répondre à des besoins
immédiats quand ville en expansion a
créé tout un secteur d'habitation mais
il ne suffit pas de loger un plan
d'urbanisme lui doit aller plus loin
l'urbanisme moderne a maintenant pour
but de créer des villes qui répondent
aux quatre fonctions logées travaillées
circulaient se cultiver mais dans ces
villes édifiées de toutes pièces il faut
permettre comme autrefois
l'épanouissement de toutes les activités
pourraient aux villes la société
d'équipements de Basse Normandie a mis
en concours le plan d'une ville de 40000
habitants sur ce terrain de 300 hectares
elle va être construite en fonction de
différents pôles d'attractions les
usines existantes et les zones
industrielles ou plusieurs milliers
d'emplois vont être créés à quelques
minutes du lieu d'habitation
[Musique]
et son université qui ajoutera au
potentiel intellectuel de la ville de
demain
et aussi la mer à quelques kilomètres
[Musique]
Hérouville se dressera sur ses prairies
et le projet de l'Union d'architecte et
d'urbanisme prévoit la ville avec un
cintre lié à six quartiers différents un
parc est des jardins des volumes variés
cet ensemble a été modelé sur le terrain
et sa silhouette et celle d'une ville de
l'importance de Chartres
l'élément de base de la ville est le
quartier dont les 5000 habitants peuvent
se connaître le chauffeur peut être
courtois car la circulation est continue
à sens unique sans croisement ni feu
quittons la route qu'aucun immeuble ne
borne après la passerelle qui nous mène
au quartier importite nous réserve la
surprise d'une place vous ne connaissez
pas ce genre de place car ici tout est
calme pas de voiture l'homme est dans
son milieu
l’espace se resserre pour retrouver le
coup d'accoud d'une rue marchande
full l'horizon se dégage la verdure
resurgit pour salir à la pierre grâce à
ses nouveaux principes d'urbanisme
Hérouville va répondre au désir de tous
ses habitants quelle que soit leur
profession leur façon de vivre leur âge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le crédit est roi pour un
achat de quelqu'un d'importance le
paiement comptant est devenu l'exception
la traitement Suède est entrée dans les
habitudes
[Musique]
mais il est un domaine où le crédit
n'avait pas encore été appliqué celui de
la contrainte par corps en Belgique le
ministre de la Justice monsieur vermelen
vient de mettre à laisser un système de
prison à tempérament cet homme par
exemple coupable d'un délit mineur a été
condamné à deux semaines de prison il
est libre il travaille mais il va
s'acquitter de sa dette pendant ses
congés hebdomadaires chaque samedi à 14h
il quitte son foyer discrètement son
employeur ses amis ne savent rien seul
sa femme est au courant il passera deux
nuits et la journée du dimanche en
prison
[Musique]
le lundi à 6h du matin il sera libre de
nouveau sa vie familiale est intacte sa
dignité n'a pas souffert dans quelques
semaines il sera redevenu un homme comme
les autres
à force de France comme chaque année le
carnaval du Mardi Gras a déroulé ses
faces à travers les rues de la ville une
foulardinte et bigarrée a défilé pendant
des heures en wagons au rythme des
Calypso et des béguines toutes les
barrières sociales ont disparu un seul
mot d'ordre s'amuser
[Musique]
et le lendemain mercredi des Cendres par
une exception unique aux Antilles la
foule martiniquaise s'est retrouvée sur
la place de la savane uniformément vêtue
de noir et de blanc couleur de deuil
pour l'enterrement du carnaval
comme on dit ici Vava les morts carnaval
est mort mais pour un an seulement
[Musique]